Les voy a pedir que levanten
la mano los que consideren
que la imagen detrás mío
corresponde a una obra de arte.
¿No hay lugar a dudas, no?
¿Qué pasa con esta otra?
Podrá gustarnos más o menos,
depende de los gustos estéticos,
pero nadie se va a horrorizar
por ver un Mondrian en un museo.
¿Qué ocurre si les muestro un urinario?
Empiezan las dudas.
No es cualquier urinario.
La fuente, presentado por Duchamp
para ingresar en una exhibición
de arte donde todas las obras
iban a ser aceptadas.
Y esta quedó afuera.
Los otros comisionados que tenían
que decidir qué entraba
la dejaron de lado.
Duchamp renunció.
Una obra de arte conceptual, irreverente,
políticamente incorrecta.
Porque a veces el arte
también se trata de eso.
¿Y esta otra?
Una caja de polvo de lavar y ni siquiera
la auténtica. Una réplica.
Pero, ¿si les digo que es de Warhol?
Las caras empiezan a cambiar.
Un nombre que valida.
Otra obra, ícono
de las vanguardias del siglo XX.
En este caso, un arte que
nos habla de lo que está sucediendo,
de arte comercial versus
arte de elite. ¿Por qué?
Porque el arte no es siempre algo lindo.
El arte no es siempre un cuadro.
De hecho, en sus orígenes
el arte fue mucho más que eso.
El arte fue ritual.
El arte fue política, fue comunicación.
Por eso el arte, a veces,
puede ser efímero, puede ser brutal,
puede horrorizarnos,
como Marina Abramovic
y sus performances
que buscan conmovernos,
que buscan comentar algo, contar.
Que son declaraciones políticas,
sociales, religiosas a veces.
O el arte puede aliarse con la ciencia
y crear una coneja como Alba.
Una coneja fosforescente
cuya paternidad se estuvo en debate
entre el artista Eduardo Kac
y el laboratorio que la encargó.
¿Es un descubrimiento?
¿Es una obra de arte?
Con esto en mente, ¿quiénes dirían que
una imagen como esta puede ser arte?
Que un videojuego, capaz,
es una de las nuevas vanguardias.
Como lo fue en su momento Duchamp.
O como lo fue en su momento Warhol.
Y no lo estoy diciendo yo, ni tampoco
lo dice un grupo de 'geeks' fanatizados
que se pasan 24 horas al día jugando
y que conocen
todos los trucos que puede haber.
No, es algo
que está sucediendo en el mundo.
Y que lo están validando instituciones.
Instituciones desde el arte
y desde la tecnología.
Museos como el Smithsonian
le dedicaron este año una exhibición
de varios meses
a la historia del videojuego.
La influencia del videojuego
en la cultura.
Y el que elegía las obras
que tenían que estar en exhibición
era el propio público.
O, por ejemplo, un museo de la tecnología,
como es el de Berlín.
Tiene un ala enteramente
dedicada a los videojuegos.
Desde la consola primera
hasta realizaciones contemporáneas
hechas por artistas que trabajan
en torno al dispositivo videojuego.
¿Y por qué no también festivales?
Como ARS Electronica. Un festival
que se realiza en Austria
que es paradigmático de lo que
es arte y tecnología.
Tiene una categoría que
se llama Arte Interactivo
y que viene premiando
hace rato videojuegos.
Videojuegos comerciales,
videojuegos independientes,
dispositivos creados por artistas.
Son distintas formas
en las que el videojuego
puede llegar a ser considerado arte.
No digo que todos lo sean,
pero algunos sí.
Y esto sucede,
y era inevitable que sucediera,
porque el arte es algo propio del hombre.
El arte es una forma
que tenemos de expresarnos,
de comunicar, de transmitir emociones.
El arte va cambiando en cada época.
Con cada sociedad va valiéndose
de distintas herramientas.
La tecnología en este siglo
era inevitable.
Y el videojuego es una de las tantas caras
que puede llegar a tomar.
Y estas son una de las tantas caras
que están detrás de estas creaciones.
Estos son quizás los próximos Warhol.
Son los que están caminando
entre nosotros.
Nosotros somos quienes vamos a decir,
"sí, puede ser arte", "no",
y el tiempo después
nos dará o no la razón.
Les propongo hacer un rápido paneo
por seis casos de videojuegos
que probablemente no sean
todavía una Mona Lisa,
o una caja como las Brillo Box de Warhol,
pero que están sentando las bases
de lo que está por venir.
La forma más rápida, quizás,
que tenemos de acercarnos es el cine.
El videojuego como un paso más.
Del séptimo arte al octavo.
Ahora hay interactividad,
algo que el arte
desde que se sale
de la tela está buscando.
Que ciertas ramas del arte buscan.
Comprometer al otro, correrlo
del lugar del observador.
Engancharlo, hacerlo protagonista.
El videojuego lo tiene de por sí.
Casos como este, Assassin's Creed,
un videojuego 'mainstream'
que puede ser vapuleado
por aquellos más 'indies'
pero que tiene mucho por detrás.
Son tres años de trabajo,
500 personas desarrollando,
departamentos dedicados a fotografía,
diseño de personajes, a narrativa.
Acá se reconstruyó la Italia renacentista.
Se trabajó con historiadores,
con arquitectos,
con especialistas en esta época.
Es la única forma que tenemos
hoy de recorrer estos lugares.
Hace poco hubo una muestra
en el Museo de Arte Decorativo
sobre cuadros de esa época.
Colas y colas interminables por tener
un acercamiento a esa instancia.
Acá es lo mismo. Nos están llevando
por un recorrido
donde nosotros somos quienes
transitamos esa historia.
Somos los protagonistas de este cuento.
Y así como Hollywood tiene
una contracara que puede ser Cannes,
o el Oso de Berlín con propuestas
que buscan contar otra historia,
transmitir otra experiencia
y que tienen otro circuito,
también lo tienen los videojuegos.
Con empresas que se presentan
como puramente artísticas.
Es el caso de That Game Company,
una empresa californiana
que dice que desarrolla videojuegos
que son como poemas interactivos.
Este es su último trabajo, Journey.
El viaje del héroe,
retomado por toda narrativa.
Cualquier libro o película
que vean habla de esto.
Acaso un viaje propio de cada uno.
Nos despertamos en el desierto,
solos en la inmensidad.
Sin nadie que nos acompañe
y una luz a la cual seguir.
En El Viaje, el significado
va a ser propio de cada uno.
Es ingresar en un cuadro,
es ingresar en un poema.
Es ser uno el que camina por esos versos.
Y a veces aparece otro personaje,
que es una persona que está conectada
en ese preciso momento que está
transitando su propio camino,
su propio destino.
Y que se conecta con nosotros
a través de sonidos,
no tenemos un lenguaje conocido,
no podemos chatear, emitimos sonidos.
Cantamos, nos comunicamos,
nos acompañamos.
Y cuando desaparece,
nos agarra una cosita...
nos quedamos solos haciendo este camino.
Hasta acá todo sencillo, parece.
Es estética, lo entendemos.
No es tan loco.
Pero, ¿qué pasa si nos ponemos
un poquito más experimentales?
Daniel Benmergui, argentino.
Trabaja con la narrativa.
¿Cómo se cuenta una historia?
Él retoma en este caso las teorías
de los constructivistas rusos.
Se metió con chiquitadas.
Storyteller, cuenta cuentos.
Ganó el Nuovo Award en la IGF,
Independent Games Festival de este año.
El premio por antonomasia en lo que es
ser experimental en un videojuego.
Él nos plantea, en el lenguaje
de historietas, un cuenta cuentos.
En este caso Adam debe morir.
Lo tenemos a Adam y una lápida.
Si ponemos a Adam en la primer viñeta
y a la lápida en la segunda, 'kaput' Adam.
A veces se inspira en citas del cine,
como puede ser Propuesta indecente.
Tenemos a esta feliz pareja, si le ponemos
un cofre, la pareja se romperá.
Depende de nosotros cual va a ser
la decisión de nuestro protagonista.
Si elige el amor o el dinero.
Está experimentando.
Nos podrá parecer arte o no,
veremos, pero está sucediendo.
Y el arte, como dijimos hoy,
puede ser también político.
El arte puede tener un mensaje
fuerte que transmitir.
En algún momento, los muralistas
de México salieron a las calles.
Salieron a las calles a hablar
de política, a educar al pueblo,
a concientizar
sobre lo que estaba sucediendo.
Aquí Gonzalo Frasca desde Uruguay
nos plantea Septiembre 12.
Inspirado en los sucesos de Septiembre 11,
nos mete en un pueblo cualquiera
en Medio Oriente.
Civiles caminando y, entre ellos,
personas armadas.
Una mira, no hay objetivos.
No hay ninguna regla.
Depende de nosotros qué hacer.
Nuestro primer instinto,
es matar al malo.
Pero entre que disparemos
y que el misil llegue va a haber heridos
que no tenían que ser
los que tenían que caer.
Los civiles se van a acercar
a llorar a sus familiares muertos
y se van a convertir
ellos también en terroristas.
La violencia engendra violencia.
Es simple.
Pero que nos lo digan no es
lo mismo que tomar conciencia
al ser nosotros los responsables
de esas acciones.
Serious Games, juegos que tienen
que ver con la realidad social,
con lo que nos está pasando.
El videojuego acercándose a la educación.
El videojuego como una herramienta
para conectarnos con los pequeños
que ya nacen
con un joystick prácticamente.
O, un videojuego experimental desarrollado
en este caso por un músico.
Deep Sea, una escafandra,
una máscara de gas
que nos aísla totalmente
de lo que tenemos alrededor
y unos auriculares.
Estamos en el fondo del mar.
Nuestra misión es escapar
de unas bestias salvajes
que nos están persiguiendo.
Tenemos el recurso de un joystick
y el sonido que escuchamos.
La experiencia. En algún momento
el arte cuando se corrió del cuadro
empezó a trabajar con el cuerpo,
con las emociones,
con los sentimientos y las sensaciones;
surgieren las performances
y los happenings.
Transitar algo, apelar
a otras sensibilidades.
Marta Minujín es un ícono acá.
Seguramente escucharon
hablar de La Menesunda.
Uno recorría una suerte
de escenario donde sucedían cosas.
Era un paso más que lo visual.
Era atravesar
la experiencia con el cuerpo.
Pero seguíamos siendo testigos.
Acá somos protagonistas.
Y, además, se abren posibilidades
para gente, por ejemplo, no vidente.
La propuesta es justamente
empezar a trabajar
con todas estas capacidades que tenemos.
Finalmente, Pain Station.
Desarrollado por artistas.
Dentro de su tesis para
recibirse en la universidad
retoman el juego del Pong,
uno de los primeros.
Un pingpong. Uno tiene
las manos dispuestas
para estar jugando en el tablero
a este tenis de mesa.
El problema es que por cada pelota
que erremos,
por cada tiro que no podamos atrapar,
la segunda mano que está ubicada
en el tablero va a recibir un castigo.
Se queman, les dan latigazos.
Este juego está en exposición
en el museo de Berlín
como un desarrollo contemporáneo
de artistas trabajando con videojuegos.
En el límite de lo ético,
del juego, del arte.
Pero de eso se trata,
de provocar los límites.
Y es importante tener en cuenta
que todas estas propuestas
están retomando el valor del juego.
Algo que capaz habíamos dejado de lado.
Que considerábamos que era de niños.
Que no es de niños.
El juego también es cosa de grandes.
El juego puede ser serio.
El juego sentó las bases de todas
las culturas y las sociedades.
El juego nos hace socializar.
Nos hace conectarnos con el otro.
Y el juego, de la mano del arte,
se puede tomar ciertas libertades.
Puede explorar, puede experimentar,
puede arriesgarse,
ser irreverente, proponer nuevas
experiencias, abrir puertas.
De eso se trata esto.
De estar atentos, de no quedarnos
cómodos en nuestros lugares
añorando tiempos pasados y mejores
donde entendíamos todo lo que veíamos.
De no quedarnos como el personaje
de Woody Allen
en Medianoche en París soñando
con viajar en el tiempo.
De darnos cuenta que alrededor nuestro
está empezando a haber cambios.
Que depende de nosotros despertar
esa curiosidad interna.
Cambiar la mirada, volver a ver.
Que hay cambios de paradigma
que se están sucediendo.
Que los videojuegos son una
de las posibles caras.
Y quizás es una forma fácil
de acercarse a este campo.
Los invito a volver a jugar.
(Aplausos)